This war is one I have to fight alone
you don't know what they have planned for you
the great Nick Fury
one last fight
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
this will be my new secret Invasion trailer
Marvel's episodes are going to be starting pretty
soon so of course I'll do videos for everything
be sure to subscribe to get the videos one of the
biggest things in the new footage is super Skrull
so a lot of you been asking how they're going
to be doing super Skrulls in the MCU they're
meant to be highly evolved versions of Skrulls
compared to the normal Skrulls like Talos in the
older generation that have been working with Nick
Fury since the 90s so I'll explain how the MCU is
doing super Skrulls a little bit differently from
the original comics in the way they're changing
the secret Invasion story from the comic book
Avengers crossover event and because Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 is coming out in theaters this
weekend I partnered with the Marvel people for a
special giveaway thank you to our sponsor today
Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy video game big
coincidence the Guardians of Galaxy 3 movies
coming out right now too I am giving away a
few copies of the game to people in the comments
more details on that in a second the video game is
a third person story driven action-adventure
Style game you play as Peter Quill Star-Lord
and are joined by different members of the
Guardians of the Galaxy at different parts of
the story the story picks up a few years after
the annihilation Conquest storyline and Marvel
Comics that was the story where this particular
roster of the Guardians came together for the
first time there were some Easter eggs for that in
the Guardians of the Galaxy 3 movie The continuity
of the game borrows from both the comics and
the Marvel movies so his backstory is a little
bit different in the game the reason why he left
Earth in the late 80s is a little bit different
but he is still from planet Earth in some of the
characters that you encounter in the game are
characters that are appearing for the first time
in live action in The Guardians of the Galaxy 3
movie the present day of the game takes place in
the early years of the Guardians of the Galaxy
team they've been together for a little while
but they do cover the events of his backstory
during the beginning the game does have different
outcomes based on the choices that you make of
Star-Lord throughout the story the soundtrack is
great is closer to James Gunn 70s 80s music from
the movies there is no DLC or microtransactions it
is a single player game and it is available right
now on all the major video game plan forms like
the PlayStation Store Xbox steam if you prefer
PC gaming so be sure to check it out and I will
pick three giveaway winners randomly from the
comments within the next few days and announce the
winner during one of my Marvel videos next week
so during the trailer you see several of the
younger Skrull characters like the younger
generation Emilia Clarke's character her
generation with special powers that the
other Scrolls don't have particularly Kingsley
Ben adir's gravic character who's the leader
of the evil faction of Scrolls within the larger
good group of Scrolls Amelia Clark is playing Gia
talos's daughter who showed up during the Captain
Marvel movie as this young girl she just gotten
older and turned into Emilia Clark here this is
what her human form looks like this is what she
looks like as a scroll she's also meant to be
one of these super scrolls with special powers
that they've evolved that Talos doesn't have and
when we talk about special abilities one of her
powers is supposed to be shooting green fire
green energy from her body so the whole idea
during the trailer like you see them constructing
this special device here it seems like they're
trying to orchestrate this super scroll plan
evolve their powers more so they can take over
the planet completely but it's just meant to be
the smaller faction of Scrolls within the large
group The Talos controls and works with Nick Fury
for those of you asking about the timeline too the
this is meant to take place before the events of
the Marvel's movie because during the trailer we
saw Nick Fury on the sword space station but
it's basically like the Peak from the comics
same basic concept except in the MCU he's working
with the Scrolls to build this to operate it take
care of planet Earth from extraterrestrial threats
in the comics that was Abigail bran so the idea is
that eventually Emilia Clark's character will
become a version of Abigail Brand I think that
she'll be using that alias in her human form but
she's really gonna be Talos' daughter G'iah the
scroll originally the super scroll was meant
to be one character and his name was color
horses I have been appointed by
Emperor amok to be your new leader
he started out as a normal scroll soldier in their
army decorated for his bravery his combat ability
he won all these accolades then fell into disgrace
got banished then to tie things more to secret
Invasion the original idea for the Skrulls to pull
off secret Invasion came from Emperor Dwho was
the emperor before princess faraki the person who
actually pulled it off came along bringing it back
around to the Fantastic Four because super Skrull
came from the Fantastic Four Comics basically
originally Emperor Dorrek is the one who tried to
invade Earth in the Fantastic Four Comics it was
way back in Fantastic Four number two in 1961.
like that's how far back it goes the Fantastic
Four wind up stopping the invasion and then he
basically takes all their powers and grafts them
onto colored making him a Skrull that has actual
special powers whereas most of the Skrulls at the
time only had the ability to change form and just
had basic super strength as part of their biology
their bodies are a little bit stronger more
resilient than human bodies in the way that all
regular asgardians who don't have special powers
just have stronger bodies and live longer same
thing with Loki's character now like Loki and Thor
are different because they do have actual special
powers like Loki practices magic Thor has actual
Celestial God Powers they're just changing this
a little bit in the MCU version giving all these
newer Skrulls like the younger generation special
powers more evolved bodies and when we talk about
them doing classic stuff from the original Comics
you remember when they started doing Tom Holland
MCU Spider-Man for Spider-Man homecoming really
all his movies in general they went back to
the original Spider-Man comic book villains
like the vulture debuted in Amazing Spider-Man
number two in a couple years after they did that
Skrull story in Fantastic Four number two the
Fantastic Four actually guest starred in that
very first Amazing Spider-Man number one issue
in 1963 we're getting all the 616 MCU versions
of the Fantastic Four really soon so you can
see how Marvel's trying to pull super deep cuts
for all these characters like secret Invasion
the MCU is meant to be a combination of these
things from the classic Comics The Very original
Fantastic Four Comics as well as the more modern
version of The Avengers secret Invasion crossover
event so originally the super Skrull was meant to
be like the one Skrull that had actual special
powers really good example the way his powers
worked originally was during the fox fantastic
4-2 Silver Surfer movie with Chris Evans human
torch character getting all their powers at the
same time and having to figure out how to use all
their powers effectively really hoping we see an
Easter egg or a reference to Chris Evans version
of the Human Torch in Deadpool 3 or Secret Wars
or some other big Multiverse movie Chris Evans has
actually talked about coming back as a character
like he just said that it'd be much easier for
him to make that decision than to come back as
actual Captain America just because the tone of
his character in the idea of him coming back as
human torch seems so tongue-in-cheek and kind of
jokey it feels like it would fit better as a
Deadpool 3 joke than say like Avengers Secret
Wars but you can let me know where you want to see
him come back as other versions of characters like
his Human Torch in the MCU somewhere but you can
see during the secret Invasion Series in the MCU
they want the whole concept of the super Skrull
idea to be bigger than and just Fantastic Four
Powers than making him just a Fantastic Four
character and they're just saying that these
Skrulls are a mutation of the previous Skrulls we
make more X-Men jokes and references because we
will see X-Men characters start popping up pretty
soon speaking of which Wolverine in Deadpool 3.
also them using a lot of Abigail brand Easter
eggs for Emilia Clarke's character even if she's
playing somebody a little bit different is them
doing more X-Men Easter eggs the other cool super
Skrull Easter egg here because they've slowly
been setting up the Young Avengers characters in
the background of all these movies and TV series
since Marvel phase 4 and now Marvel phase five one
of the next characters who was on that original
team was the hulkling character who's secretly the
grandson of that original Skrull Emperor Dorrek
who fought the Fantastic Four and got the idea
to pull off secret Invasion but died before they
actually were able to pull it off the reason why
hookling is green why he calls himself huckling
has nothing to do with him being a Hulk or having
gamma Powers it's just because he's a green Skrull
and because he's so thick like he's so he's huge
he does also have some some special powers like
these evolved versions of schools these super
Skrulls that we see in the MCU version of The
Secret Invasion trailer too there've been a lot of
you asking whether or not they're actually going
to do hulkling in this new MCU secret Invasion
series or tease the character somehow it's always
possible the main new characters though that I
think they're trying to introduce in a big way
are mostly Amelia Clarke's character and the other
super Skrulls who have powers now like I said
I think the long-term plan for Emilia Clarke's
character just based on what we've heard about the
series so far is that they'll set her up with an
alias of Abigail brand and she'll become a version
of that character working with Nick Fury and I
think the idea is that she's going to take her
father's place because her father Talos has been
working with a fury basically doing that it does
seem like he almost dies or he winds up dying at
some point during the trailer like she's cradling
his body here as he's all messed up everyone pour
one out for Talos press F to pay respects you
can let me know in the comments if you think
he's actually gonna die during the series or they
just want to make us think that he's going to die
Nick Fury certainly keeps saying that during
the trailer like One Last Ride one last time
the funny thing about that there's been so many
twists that have killed him off and that brought
him back like the snap and the blip Samuel L
Jackson said that he would come back as many
times as they would have him like he does have a
contract for a bunch of movies but he keeps asking
them like every time there's a movie that comes
along how come I'm not in this one usually it's
very tongue-in-cheek like Kevin foggy will be like
no no you're gonna be in this other stuff don't
worry we're gonna put you in some more stuff now
everybody asking him when he's going to come back
as Mace Windu in the Star Wars movies and series
and speaking of Fantastic Four there have been a
lot of casting announcements we're supposed to get
the official cast pretty soon so of course I'll do
more Fantastic Four videos separately as we learn
more about those characters real big reminder
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 is coming out this
weekend be sure to go see it as soon as possible
my post credit scene video full Easter eggs
breakdown will start posting in the next couple
of days as it comes out in theaters everyone
click here for all those videos I'll update
the link as soon as I post those and click here
for all my other Marvel secret Invasion trailer
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!